so i have to address of course for one
division there were these crazy theories
going out there
uh fans kind of got carried away um
you know is mephisto this is methysto
this i'll just ask is there
we were kind of fake teased about a
secret cameo at the end of one of vision
are there any cameos or characters that
are going to be introduced that you
think might shock people
well i hope so
[Laughter]
okay um is bucky mephisto
good question let's start that rumor
hey hey gary are you very nice to meet
you i like your shirt
oh thank you so much uh let me just say
as as someone who talks about marvel
every day
uh this is just truly exciting for me to
be speaking with you today
and i'd also want to say thank you
because the falcon in the winter soldier
has easily become one of my favorite
marvel projects
just ever fantastic oh that's so nice of
you to say
fantastic i i truly do love it the first
episode
is is really there's a lot of different
levels to it there's action
it's really exciting it's funny there's
a lot of emotion to it
i think right off in the first episode
you can feel captain america's presence
but you can also kind of feel his
absence as well
and i think that's because steve rogers
had such a deep connection to both
sam and bucky so i was wondering how
much consideration was given
to how that personal relationship that
each of them had
to steve rogers affected not only them
personally but their relationship with
each other because he's what connected
them well yeah that's i mean that's a
you're very insightful
if you know they both are dealing with
the loss of a friend
um and they're both dealing with you
know the loss of a time in their lives
uh a past that is now everything's
changed
we're post blip so um both are really
struggling to find their relevance uh
how to go forward
from different from different places sam
who was given the shield uh to take it
on
it doesn't necessarily want to i mean
what is it for a black man to carry that
shield
um what is it for the for you know the
optics of him in a black community for
him in a white community does he want to
deal with that
um you know there's a really uh strong
racial component to it that
um makes that decision not easy
uh and bucky also um has to
going forward figure out where does he
fit into this new world
uh he gets his mind back but um now what
and uh and even says you know now what
and and right
what's the future for him and this is a
guy who has
uh done a lot of heinous things uh while
you know under the cloud of
um brainwashing but now if he's gonna
go forward he's gonna have to heal
somehow so
and the two of them in amongst that are
kind of lonely they don't they've lost
their good friends so um you know by as
you said by
by his absence it sort of makes him very
present
i love that and you can definitely tell
that
you address that in the show with you
know with the counseling
with talking about how bucky is alone
you know going through his phone
i think that's addressed very very well
and i think a lot of people could
probably
relate to that during this time of the
pandemic
so yeah i mean it's very what it was
striking you know as we were
um filming and and i mean we always
started with this as the dna in our
story
it wasn't like because the blip was the
blip you know
so it was all there but then weirdly the
world kind of
went on a very similar track so
i i feel like our story is incredibly
timely and relevant
um and that we're touching on um what
i'm very proud of is that we really
touch on tremendously you know difficult
conversations
and we have them and we don't shy away
from them and what's wonderful about
both marvel and the mcu universe is it's
they're politically charged underneath
the you know the fun and the gloss
is a very politically charged
conversation that's just you know ever
present
and um i've been thrilled to be part of
that conversation
and you know our our goal is not to tie
it up in a bow
uh the goal is to open doors and
um you know foster further conversations
so that people
i hope you know thinking um
as they've gone for this wonderful ride
with our characters
um hopefully it will resonate with them
and stay
but i think it definitely will and i
love that it's addressing those things
and i think this is going to be
much like that shield uh a hope for some
people a symbol of hope for them i agree
i love how you you addressed all that
and speaking
speaking sorry go ahead no thank you for
that that's great it sounds like you
really
you're spot on you you're ticking all
the boxes you got it all
oh thank you no all the credit to you
because truly
again i it was amazing i truly enjoyed i
can't wait to watch the rest
um you know you mentioned the
brainwashing and and bucky's past
uh zemo is a character that's going to
be returning and he's more of a
complicated character as well because he
was a good person
but due to you know such a tragic
incident that happened with his family
he is now set up for revenge we saw him
in civil war he took his revenge
went to prison now he's back what is it
like to direct
somebody a character like that that
once was good but is now so set on
revenge
is there any hope for him are there
going to be different layers to this
character that we're going to see
throughout the show
well what i can tell you is uh whatever
it is you expect from him
um it won't happen so
it's always the unexpected with amc
uh yeah well i love that i love that
because that's
you know that's just what we like i love
to be surprised that's what i think
everybody likes
so i have to address of course for one
division there were these crazy
theories going out there uh fans kind of
got carried away
um you know is mephisto this is memphis
of this
i'll just ask is there we were kind of
fake teased about
a secret cameo at the end of one of
vision are there any cameos or
characters that are going to be
introduced that you think
might shock people well i hope so
[Laughter]
okay um is bucky mephisto
good question let's start that rumor
no i think uh i think with the way the
show is going to go
i think we're going to have plenty
plenty plenty of things to talk about
exactly one thing i'm really excited
about is the return
of emily von kamp sharon carter um she's
been in winter soldier
civil war it looks like she's going to
have a bigger role in this show
is she going to be sorry no go ahead
she's terrific and uh you know she was
on the run for a long time
so um uh we we get to meet up with her
again and find out what's been happening
is this going to be kind of her defining
portrayal
of the character is she going to be very
different than we've seen before
we're going to see i mean uh anyone
who's been on the run for a while
is affected by you know the very fact
that they've been away from
from you know life as they knew it so
yes everything's changed for her and and
um
yeah we're gonna we're gonna meet you
know she's terrific she's a lovely
actress
and um her stunt sequences are fantastic
oh that's amazing can't wait to see
those stun sequences very badass
awesome can't wait uh from the trailers
that i've seen because it wasn't in the
first episode it does truly look pretty
amazing so
very very excited to see that um as the
director
of the show it seems like there's a lot
of important messages that i personally
took away
and i think other people will take a lot
of those important messages
away as well as the director is there
one
off the top of your head specific thing
you'd like the viewers to
take away from the show yeah you know i
think um
overall the the goal you know it has
been this conversation
about uh the shield and what it is to
take up the shield and what does the
shield represent
and i think one of the big conversations
that we um
you know take on and don't as i said
don't tie up necessarily in a nice neat
bow
but is um you know what is the warrior
or what is the
hero of today because the shield was was
born of a time
you know a post-war where a hero looked
like a very particular thing which was
soldier or warrior
right and typically that's sort of where
we sort of pocketed that
idea that notion and then um as time
went on that's
that's quite an old concept when you
think about it and now sure
uh i think after 9 11 even uh we sort of
started to change that idea and hero
became a first responder and so now
you know i'd love people in our
conversation to have their opinion every
the shield will mean something different
to everybody and um
so if we have that ongoing conversation
i think that's important
i love that and i i think you're
absolutely right especially during these
times it's going to mean something
different
for each individual that watches it i
specifically could resonate
with sam and his family specifically
his sister and their situation i think a
lot of people could resonate with that
as it is right now um so i love that
amount of realism
that is incited uh yeah we're a very
interested we're a very grounded world
you know and that if if
end game was a fantastic spectacle and
you know very otherworldly
we're the exact opposite we are very
grounded very very
real world with real world issues and so
um and and that's also what i love about
uh working with both marvel and mcu is
that
pivots you know so you never know what
to expect which is really
uh is so much fun absolutely and it was
just
once again it was a fantastic show i
know we're out of time here i want to
thank you so much for this time
and again as a true fan i loved the
first episode
of the fountain soldier and i look
forward to watching the rest of it
terrific thank you so much thank you
corey bye bye
bye